let's watch this for a sec
you having fun tonight so far oh yeah
most definitely yeah um i had to chat
with dana earlier he said that i could
fight any eight-year-old i want in
arlene yeah we're setting this up yeah
have you picked out an eight-year-old to
fight i'm thinking any like rich toy
reviewer on youtube
the biggest payout
maybe who
well i mean my son jay i'm not gonna say
any names you have to say ryan's
toys was a joke
i'm bringing all 100 years of pain that
after she was like all right wrap it up
wrap it up wrap it up
it's also funny because i think ryan's
toys is like he's 10. 16. now he's 10
okay i was like it's been he's been
eight forever yeah whatever man that
kid's been reviewing toys forever and
they just keep pretending he's the same
age he's like dad i don't even like
these [ __ ] things anymore can you
imagine just review it 2016 chain
smoking yeah
this is the lego millennium falcon
i don't know dad what's the line
ripping his jewel yeah
um
yeah so you're you had a celebrity
encounter yeah yeah okay i had an
encounter oh wait damn it i don't know
if i can leak this
but i'm gonna
so i'm not gonna name names but someone
from the ufc's team told me that dana
white
saw us
roasting [ __ ] friday no way
and apparently that's the hardest
they've seen him laugh in a long time no
way specifically when i got him with
that tastes like eating a care bear's
[ __ ]
apparently he was bleeping no way
so
so can we like i don't know dana dana's
team if you're watching this
put us on
dude we want to eat some care bear [ __ ]
with the man himself yes we do
we have to do something with him yeah so
you know okay so yeah this is one this
i'm talking about this is a star-studded
episode we got
rocky we got dana white we got gary vee
coming on later by the way we haven't
said that yet but he's literally coming
on this episode later he said he'd do it
and he's coming on
and uh now i got this story okay so you
know the the
quarterback for the and i'm gonna name
names because i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm was
embarrassed as [ __ ] for a little bit but
i'm just gonna say it
i'm just gonna come out and say it all
right okay
the quarterback for the detroit lions
jared goff used to be the quarterback
for the rams right yeah okay
i saw him in cabo right he was at this
place that i was at
and uh it was like a kind of like a spa
type situation was he a jet ski as well
he was not on a jet ski
uh yeah
uh it was like a spa situation was like
a cold plunge and like a hot tub and we
were all chilling around that area and
then there was like this little like
lounge area we can get a drink or
whatever and
my friend comes out and he's like yo
what the jared goff's in there what the
[ __ ]
and uh i knew his name because of the
because he played for the rams right and
so but i'm like not that much of a
football fan so all my friends were kind
of freaking out
and uh i was just like that's cool
that's really cool but i don't really
know what he looks like but i sort of do
and i walked in and he
he's like yo
and puts out his hand and shakes my hand
i'm walking with my buddy and he's like
what the [ __ ] how do you know and i'm
like i don't and he's like yo we we met
at the uh
the softball game right and i was like
yup
i just [ __ ] lied
i lied right to his face i said yes i
didn't know what else to do
i said yeah yep
good to see you bro and i just kept it
going and he was like he was like yeah
man that was crazy it's been it's how
you been and i was like oh you know
still playing softball just doing my
thing you know
i didn't say that but i was like man i'm
just chilling i'm doing good how are you
doing he's like yeah you know just
enjoying some time off and i was like i
get it you know yeah not really because
you're an nfl quarterback but i get you
you know
and we're like
and then his buddy was sitting at the
table and his buddy goes or he goes yo
uh by the way this is cody
and i'm like
so so you do
what the [ __ ] and and i shake the guy's
hand he's like yeah i met him at this
like so-and-so charity softball game and
the guy was like oh word i didn't like i
was there too or something we didn't and
i was like yeah
crazy day
you know that softball game we raised so
much money
we really did it and uh
and so my [ __ ] walked away
and my buddy's like how do you know
jared goff and i was like dude i don't
so
jared if you're watching i want to
apologize for lying right to your face i
never played in any softball game ever
i've never played softball in my life i
know your name
didn't didn't like you didn't you play
with him on stream or something one time
no no i i could have sworn it was like i
played because of that i played with a
raider and i played with brett phillips
the pitcher yeah yeah yeah the baseball
guy yeah yeah okay so that's what i was
thinking about i was like maybe it was
from that
but it wasn't i mean maybe he just like
saw recognized me from youtube or
something like that and just like
tried to figure out where he knew me
from but didn't figure it out so i'm
sorry that's my bad i should have said
no
what i wanted to seem cool from my
friend honestly so i was just like yeah
dude
what if as you were walking up he like
leaned over to his buddies like watch
this
[Laughter]
my girlfriend like watches this guy's
youtube videos that's cool man
because we never played in a softball
game i'm like dude i know
i was just we were busting each other
right right
that's what i'm saying it's like the
softball game right
where you suck my dick
i would have said yeah yeah what is it
yeah i sucked on it
nice nice dick by the way
oh man
he's just really embarrassed you know
this is the game
oh my god how shitty is it to lie about
playing for a [ __ ] charity game
that's so shitty
yeah is this ring about all the kids
with [ __ ] terminal illnesses that you
helped out dude nice
nice
yeah all those kids that you lend your
platform to to raise money for good
thing jared goff remembers that great
memory you guys shared together
dude
i've never felt worse you're you're
gonna go into our life when you die
you're gonna go to heaven and [ __ ]
god it's gonna be like he's gonna be
god's gonna be like yo
cody right
you're at the celebrity
softball game
yeah
he's gonna be like nope just hit a
switch
wait no
you're just down there with ronald
reagan
[Laughter]
oh dude
jared i'm sorry man please
hit me up
yeah why this time just hit him up man
jared i just wanna let you know i i'd
never lied to you man i totally
[ __ ] you i lie i tell it right to your
face hey
softball game i'd be like nah
you imagine
yo from the softball game nope
just
oh okay yeah i never played there yeah
never did that so
i don't know what your dumbass is
thinking about
maybe it says cte this